300 euros pour les fonctionnaires pensez
vous que cette mesure est soit suffisant
pour atténuer le mal être de nos forces
de sécurité intérieure vous faire n'est
autre que chez au mériot riera rechi
allez-vous répondre aux besoins du
terrain pour parler de ceux de l'avenir
de demain de tout à l'heure avec
christophe castaner nous allons recevoir
les organisations syndicales nous ne
pouvions pas le faire avant sur ces
mesures là parce que nous étions ça ne
vous a pas échappé en période
d'élections professionnelles et en
période d'élections professionnelles
on ne discute pas à ce sujet mais nous
avons parfaitement en tête avec
christophe castaner il ya effectivement
le sujet du temps de travail
effectivement et nous allons nous
attacher nous atteler à ce sujet il ya
le sujet des cycles horaire aussi que
nous allons examiner et bien évidemment
le sujet des heures supplémentaires et
christophe castaner en a parlé nous
allons engager un plan d'apurement mais
en veillant à ce que ne se reconstitue
pas un stock et ça ça sera dans le cadre
d'une discussion courageuses que nous
venions mènerons avec les organisations
syndicales
elles attendent beaucoup du temps de
travail nous allons dialoguer avec avec
elle pas plus tard que ce soir
et puis dans les tout premiers jours du
mois de janvier mais nous sommes
déterminés à faire aboutir ses réformes
qui sont très attendus par nos
fonctionnaires de police et nous
n'oublions pas bien évidemment dans ces
mesures également tout ce qui est prévu
pour la gendarmerie nationale mais
pardon ce ne sont pas des mesurettes
nous avons une ambition forte pour nos
forces de l'ordre celle d'accroître et
d'augmenter les conditions dans
lesquelles elles exercent un métier
extrêmement difficile je vous remercie
la semaine dernière alors que 24
millions de nos concitoyens étaient
devant leur poste de télévision pour
écouter la réponse solennel du président
de la république car la demande sur le
pouvoir d'achat la demande sociale mais
aussi la demande de considération celui
ci nous a parlé d'un débat sur
l'immigration et l'identité nationale il
a étonné beaucoup
certains n'ont pas compris d'autres ont
trop compris j'aimerais que vous
puissiez nous dire ce que le président
entendait par là ce qu'il attend du
débat sur cette question
quatre thèmes ont été retenus le premier
sur la transition écologique le deuxième
sur la fiscalité le troisième sur
organisation d'états des trafics et le
quatrième sur la question de la
démocratie de la citoyenneté et de la
question migratoire et le présent la
république n'a pas lié dans son propos
et je sais votre honnêteté
intellectuelle sur le sujet
l'immigration et l'identité nationale
vous le savez très bien ça c'était un
débat qui appartenait au passé et dont
chacun a en mémoire le succès somme
toute relatif l'objectif qui est celui
du gouvernement et vous le savez
monsieur le sénateur vous avez été
attentif à ce qui s'est dit sur les
ronds-points depuis des semaines
désormais la question migratoire était
présente sur ces ronds-points ne pas la
traiter dans le cas de ce grand débat
national serait pour le dire crûment
faire la politique de l'autruche ne pas
considérer que c'est un sujet important
et c'est un sujet important qui mérite
mieux que les caricatures auquel nous
avons eu droit depuis des semaines sur
les recoins mais parfois aussi sur les
plateaux de télévision lorsque par
exemple certains parlementaires ont
évoqué ont évoqué le pacte de marrakech
en brandissant les peurs je crois
monsieur le sénateur que vous êtes
attaché griveaux
muet s'il vous plaît mais j'aimerais
conclure harry j'aimerais avoir la
tension navia liseron conclusion
monsieur le sénateur le sujet est trop
important
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
rappellent que je vais juge fort de la
séance mais je rappelle à tous que c'est
moi qui préside la séance et moi seul
elle sera reprise à 17h55 pour la suite
de l'examen de la proposition de loi
pour faciliter la sortie de la division
cette saison rage
[Musique]